salut les animaux sont bien plus
intelligents que nous le pensons mais
j'aurais font des trucs très stylé
certains ont des capacités comptes
n'avaient jamais soupçonnée est ce que
vous saviez par exemple que les dauphins
ont le sens des affaires et qui peuvent
deal et des mouettes jour du poisson je
vous parlais de ça ou encore que des
rats peuvent avoir de l'empathie envers
l'un des leurs qui liera enfermé dans
une cage bref loïc c'est avec empathie
les sens des affaires du coup que je te
propose un générique contre une mouette
[Musique]
on va commencer aujourd'hui par le sens
des affaires des dauphins qui est
vraiment très intéressant juste avant
que ça commence
je voulais juste vous dire que merci de
l'accueil que vous faites au cabinet
curieuse de salé le nouveau format qu'on
a lancé au mois de mai dès le deuxième
numéro sur l'affairé xavier dupont de
ligonnès alors ça a bien marché donc ça
j'étais content par contre il y avait
pas mal de commentaires sur deux types
de commentaires sur le côté négatif sur
le côté positif ça c'était très cool sur
le négatif c'était oui c'est dommage
qu'il n'apporte rien de plus et tu
oublies des éléments de la sphère le
deuxième c'est allah c'est dommage n'a
pas donner ton avis
les cabinets curieuse c'est fait pour
être factuel en fait qu'on s'y est
factuelle pour avoir une vision globale
d'un fait historique ou d'un fait divers
ou d'un fait actuelle en tout cas et
surtout sans donner de fait nous et sans
apporter mon avis personnel parce que là
on serait plus dans du factuel liste
pour la faire xavier dupont de ligonnès
beaucoup de choses qui ont été dites
dans des commentaires sont défectueuses
ou des choses qui n'ont pas été
confirmées donc c'est pour ça que j'en
ai pas parlé et je n'ai pas mon avis
pour que ça reste factuel on a même eu
un article sur ce sujet là avec livre
dans télérama qui ont apprécié la vidéo
parce qu'ils ont compris le sens du truc
de au delà de tout ce qui existe et tout
ce qui se raconte là dessus sur le sujet
où ça part dans tous les sens ça c'était
une vidéo que sur du bois voilà c'était
le la petite parenthèse qui fait plaisir
beaucoup parlent on parle ont du sens
des affaires des dauphins les dauphins
sont très intelligents ils ont parfois
des comportements mon gars très stylée
avec les êtres humains et aller voir le
dernier les dingues
certains d'entre eux par exemple ont été
étudiés aux bahamas sont capables de
laisser leurs petits en nourrice aux
humains qui les étudie pendant de
plusieurs dizaines de minutes bon
business bien entre les dauphins et les
chercheurs des coups ensemble ça fait
plusieurs années qu'ils les étudient
mais quand même c'est quand même dingue
de développer cette confiance envers une
autre espèce un institut for marine
mammal studies qui se trouve au
mississippi des dauphins ont prouvé
qu'ils ont un gros sens des affaires de
vous vraiment que je vous explique ce à
dire qu'en des déchets sont apportées
par le vent le bassin des dauphins les
dresseurs travail avec les dauphins pour
faire le nettoyage pour un déchet quelle
que soit sa taille que le dauphin ramène
aux chercheurs aux dresseurs le dauphin
reçoit un poisson en récompense ils
femelle dauphin ça peut être qu'il a
très bien compris le système et c'est à
leur mise à faire une réserve de déchets
planqué sous un poids au fond de l'eau
et dès qu'il ya un dresseur qui
passaient l arraché un petit bout de
sincère de déchets et l'amener au
dresseur qui le dément une poisse on l'a
déjà c'est quand même très malin mais ça
s'arrête pas là elle a compris qu'elle
lui autre chose ne peut plus
problématique au final à chaque fois
qu'il y avait un oiseau qui tombé par
accident dans le bassin elle le ramener
au dresseur comme un déchet et elle
avait le droit à plusieurs poissons d'un
coup et la kelly à ces dix là un truc à
faire il ya un coup à jouer kelly a
alors échangé un déchet de sa réserve
contre un poisson qu'elle n'a pas mangé
et qu'elle a gardée c'est incroyable et
qu'elle a gardée dans le bassin pour
appâter une mouette et que la moyenne
est plus poli el show plein fouet pour
le porter au dessert pendant allez allez
tomber c'est sûr et comme ça le gagner
plein de poissons retour et on sait pas
si kelly à la fait ça uniquement pour sa
conso perso aussi situé pour d'idées ça
mais en tout cas au bout d'un moment ils
tous les dauphins du bassin sont devenus
quasiment tous des gros dealer de moi tu
as les mouettes elle par contre pas très
maligne part à moisn l ont jamais
compris le danger un peu les autrichiens
partent chercher un problème jamais à me
tient aux boissons dans le bassin
voulait c'est l'hiver en vrai fou comme
1 de la démarche mental où le dauphin se
dit ok je vais prendre les déchets jeu
des gardes et je vais le planqué au fond
du bois saint parce qu'il faut pas
qu'ils les voient je mette un poids pour
pas que ça remonte et puis en fait avec
un déchet je peux avoir un poisson avec
le poisson
j'ai attiré une mouette et cette mode là
si je leur apporte j'aurai plus de poids
sont donc moins le poisson que j'ai
perdu ça vaut le coup c'est un peu une
saillie
parlons maintenant des orques le grand
public connaît bien les orques notamment
et surtout malheureusement en raison de
leur présence dans certains parcs
animaliers tend à disparaître et tant
mieux on sait aussi que plusieurs
dresseur de ses parcs ont déjà été
attaqués par ces mammifères marins
certains allant jusqu'à perdre la vie
comme dawn brancheau qui était dresseuse
au parc sea world en floride qui se fait
tuer à la fin d'une représentation en
public
parent alors que dont elle s'occupait
depuis 16 ans et c'est pas pour rien
qu'on les appelle aussi les baleines
tueuses y avait quand même un 10 dans le
nom de l'orc ce n'est pas un animal de
compagnie mais certains de ces animaux
sont plus courtois que d'autres surtout
quand ils sont dans leur milieu naturel
en liberté endroits où ils n'attaquent
pas du tout les hommes à fait à la base
alexandra morton une scientifique
travaillait auprès d'un groupe d'orques
en liberté a justement pu observer leur
hospitalité alors qu'elle était sur
l'eau dans une petite embarcation qui
était plongée dans le brouillard
alexandra était à la limite de se perdre
en haute mer pas très rassuré se
demander comment elle allait rentrer
quand les orques sont arrivés et se sont
regroupés autour du bateau et llc fier à
son instinct à la relation qu'elle avait
tissés avec les animaux et a les a suivi
elle a pu retrouver la côte une
vingtaine de minutes plus tard
directement le groupe est ensuite
retourné à ses affaires une fois
qu'alexandra était en sécurité
donc en fait mais pas des tueuses wii
sont en captivité mais libres sont très
sympas de limites airbnb c'est peut-être
déjà passé dans un aéroport ou des
chiens reniflent et vos bagages pour
être sûr que vous n'aviez pas avec vous
de la drogue ou des explosifs certains
détectent même des séismes ou encore des
fuites de gaz en 2019 une étude
américaine a dévoilé que les chiens
pouvaient également être efficace dans
la détection de cancers
incroyable quand même il ya des beagles
sq ont été entraînés à renifler les
échantillons sanguins et à faire la
différence entre ceux qui étaient
normaux et ceux issus d'un patient
atteint d'un cancer
en fait il ya un manque d'odeurs des
cellules quand il ya des cellules
cancérigènes et c'est ça que les chiens
détecte les chiens ont par la suite
réussi à identifier les échantillons de
patients touchés par le cancer dans 96
7% des quartiers incroyable alors l'idée
n'est pas nouvelle puisque déjà en 1989
une femme était allée voir son
dermatologue en lui disant que son chien
n'arrêtait pas de lui renouveler le l'un
de ces grains de beauté qui s'avérait
être cancéreux il ya de nombreuses
autres anecdotes du même genre en
allemagne à des chiens qu'on carrément
réussi à détecter des cancers du poumon
directement depuis l'haleine des
patients en france les chiens en trouver
des cancers de la prostate vial urines
des patients bref ça n'arrête pas une
étude menée en france a également permis
de montrer que des chiens sont capables
de détecter le commis de 19 en un
dixième de seconde
reniflant la sueur des patients est vite
quand même des deux groupes tout dans
les labs alors attention débat le
covilha qu'ovide dites moi en
commentaire qu'est ce que vous dites moi
je dit le co vide pourquoi parce que le
dictionnaire a tranché le dictionnaire
il va utiliser ce qui est le plus
employé en fait c'est plus logique donc
de la tranchée pour le copie et c'est
l'académie française qui avait dit l'aco
vide moi j'aurais sur le coup vide on
peut être voilà sur un truc logique bon
alors taux de réussite pour la détection
du comique et entre 90 et 99 % selon les
chiens c'est plus sympa que tu es
spéciales es16 l'expression avoir une
mémoire d'éléphant elle n'est pas tirée
de nulle part les éléphants en
excellente mémoire mais sont également
extrêmement intelligent et ça on n'en
parle pas assez dense et baba il
représente de ne pas trop les clés de
compréhension
les éléphants vivent dans des sociétés
matriarcales complexe donc j'ai réparé
par la mer par la femme était sont
notamment capables de saisir la
hiérarchie humaines et de la comprendre
on sait que la joie est très présente
dans leur palette d'émotions mais de
deuil pourrait également en faire partie
comme nous montre cette histoire quand
un directeur de refuge d'éléphant et
décider en 2012
une douzaine d'éléphants a traversé la
réserve pour venir passer deux jours à
côté de son habitation représente
vraiment un deuil pourtant leur leur
relation n'était pas parti du bon pied
puisque le clan de neuf éléphants dont
lawrence anthony s'est occupé au départ
était très méfiant envers les hommes
lana la matriarche elephant faisait
tomber les clôtures pour permettre aux
siens de ne pas être retenu dans la
réserve et la technique de laurent
dessus alors d'oublier les clôtures et
de tenter de faire comprendre à nana qui
en fait elle serait bien dans cet
endroit et qu'ils étaient en sécurité il
est allé vivre avec plusieurs jours il
les a nourris leur a parlé et il a il a
eu vote aux raisons parce qu'il n'a pas
du tout fonctionné mais un jour une
jeune éléphante dont la famille a été
décimée lui a été remise
l'anah a répondu à l'appel de l'os est
venu réconforter la nouvelle arrivante
une fois que nana et son clan ont été
rassurés ils sont ils sont restés dans
la réserve de rennes ce qui les a
laissés tranquilles parce que c'était le
butin ce n'est pas un zoo
le 2 mars 2012 lawrence est mort d'une
crise cardiaque il avait 61 ans pendant
les funérailles nana et son clan sont
arrivés devant la maison et d'après la
famille ça faisait un an et demi qu'il
n'était pas venu jusque là ils auraient
pu mettre plusieurs heures pour arriver
jusque là est ce que c'était un deuil
est-ce que c'était une coïncidence
comment ils ont pu en tissu
et les funérailles théorie dans les
commentaires bon alors les fourmis elles
sont complètement ou dans leur genre je
suis passionné par les fourmis depuis
1991 grâce ou à cause du premier roman
de bernard werber
on vend pas les formes sont si
intelligente en intelligence collective
qu'elles ont réussi à coloniser
l'ensemble de la planète des régions les
plus chaudes aux régions les plus
froides à elles ont traversé le temps et
tous les problèmes elles n'ont peur de
rien ce sont les fourmis tu as tort dans
le faux
quel est le principal facteur qui leur a
permis cet exploit bassil altruisme les
formes y vivent pour la communauté pas
en communauté mais pour la commune quand
même une grande différence avec nous
nous on vit en communauté
voilà il existe d'ailleurs des formes
policières qui ont beau job d'éloigner
les fourmis qui ont un comportement
inapproprié inadapté à la vie en société
il arrive même que certaines d'entre
elles soit exécutée fait pas bon être
égoïste au pays de la formule as-tu
pensé pour ta gueule hba ta pub state un
exemple de leur altruisme chez certaines
espèces des fourmis ont pour tâche de
faire pousser des champignons pour
nourrir leurs nombreuses qu'on gêne un
petit détail au passage les fourmis ont
inventé l'agriculture
d'autres élèves des pucerons pour la
consommation de leur vie est là pour et
pour ensuite le manger et en échange
elles protègent les pucerons des
coccinelles un petite info au passage
elles ont inventé les vagues ce qu'elles
font avec les pucerons c'est exactement
ce que nous faisons avec les vaches on
leur prend leur plaît et on les tue
ensuite pour manger leur viande
bon sauf qu'on ne protège pas d'un
danger pour les vaches c'est plutôt nohl
dangereux mais il ya plein d'autres
exemples qui existent les fourmis
tisserandes qui forme des passerelles
avec leur corps pour permettre au groupe
de passer d'une branche à l'autre ou de
traverser une rivière par exemple s'il
ya un trou a passé ses selles dans la
taille correspond le plus à celui du
trou qui va s'y mettre ton le combler
elle se sacrifie pour la communauté et
pour traverser des cours d'eau elle crée
carrément des radeaux entier avec leur
corps ah si seulement certains humains
pouvaient prendre exemple sur elle bon
en même temps j'ai pas envie de faire du
rafting sur le corps de quelqu'un mais
juste sans tomber dans l'extrême si
l'empathie cette chose qui disparaît
pour certains à partir du moment où il
monte au volant de leur voiture
rassurez-vous certaines espèces sont
prêtes à prendre notre relève dans
l'empathie comme le montre cette étude
ara conva appelé michel a été enfermé
dans une petite cache en plastique
transparentes où il avait à peine la
place de tourner sur lui-même de
l'intérieur impossible de michel
d'ouvrir la cage en revanche de
l'extérieur un mécanisme très simple
permettait de l'ouvrir bernard arrive
c'est un autre en avant le fait non il a
été mis dans la même pièce que michel
mais à l'extérieur de la cage totalement
libre de ses mouvements au bout de
quelques jours et de plusieurs blessés
bernard a réussi à libérer michel donc
il voulait le libérer on sait pas encore
si c'est le défi de comprendre le
mécanisme car à tirer vraiment bernard
ou si c'est le sort de michèle qu'il
touchait au point de le faire sortir de
là du coup on a tenté le même expérience
avec une cage vide ou bien dans lequel
on mettrait un objet inanimé et bella
bernard mais la pomme bouge tes
l'intéressait pas donc c'était vraiment
pour libérer son copain michel mais les
scientifiques sont allés plus loin et
ils vont toujours un peu plus loin des
fois ils ont trop bon en fait qu'il
voulait c'était voir jusqu'à quel point
leur avait de l'empathie envers le
prisonnier ils ont donc une nouvelle
fois enfermés michel et ils ont mis du
chocolat dans une deuxième cache à côté
en gros c'est libère le chocolat ou
libère michel moi je crois que michel
c'était de la mayo halles place du
chocolat tu as dans sa cage sauf que
bernard dans tous les cas ouvrez les
deux cages il tait fois il y libérer le
chocolat en premier parfois michel mais
dans tous les cas le chocolat était
consommée après l'ouverture des deux
cages c'est d'abord il ouvrait la
première ou la deuxième
ensuite il faisait l'autre et ensuite
une fois que mimi il était parmi nous on
allait manger le choco bernard attendait
donc son copain michel pour partager
l'europe
les animaux vont toujours nous étonner
ils ont une intelligence incroyable
depuis une cinquantaine d'années la
vision de l'intelligence animale a
évolué avec la découverte de la pensée
sans langage ça c'est juste fou nous on
est tous en colocation sur terre juste
se rappeler qu'on a tous besoin d un d
autre qu un équilibre en fait si on veut
qu'elle tourne correctement le plus
longtemps possible parce que même la
terre à la pas besoin de nous en fait
peu importe que ce soit un caillou pas
en fait c'est nous qui avons besoin que
la terre soit en bonne santé
si en plus on arrivait à prendre en
compte l'intelligence de tous les êtres
qui vivent
on ferait quand même un grand pas en
avant dites moi dans les commentaires si
vous voulez qu'on fasse plus de vidéos
sur les spécificités animal
l'intelligence animale les relations
animal qui sont parfois proches de
l'homme
donc voilà on pourra explorer ce sujet
là ça dépendra du nombre de vues de
cette vidéo du nombre de likes donc si
ça vous plaît d'être commentées partager
la haie et fait la vivre l'épisode 2 ne
dépend que de vous ben c'est normal que
les vidéos pour moi et pourront bientôt
bientôt on se revoit la partir de
septembre la tournée reprend la tournée
du spectacle a tourné des dédicaces en
france en belgique en suisse via la
grande dernière du spectacle au zénith
de paris le 11
sambre n'hésitez pas à passer sur mon
site leur gré dans la description si
vous voulez me rejoindre sur l'un de ces
événements
moi je m'appelle comment je m'appelle je
m'appelle sébastien olivier faux fabien
olicard arrêté de m'appeler avec les
mauvais non n'oubliez pas de vous
abonner à cette chaîne
et n'oubliez pas d'activer la cloche
pour ne pas rater la prochaine vidéo
bientôt les deux millions d'abonnés
grâce à vous merci c'est dingue la jouer
deux autres vidéos ça
ces deux vidéos c'est sur des
expériences stylet qui ont été faites
sur le cerveau très intéressante prenez
soin de vous à très bientôt
loïc cette eau qui le dit c'est toi qui
le dit c'est après à très bientôt
prenez soin de vous à très bientôt au
revoir non non non attendez réalise
prenez soin de vous à très bientôt
cheechoo non chapiteau d'accord checked
à très bientôt
chapiteau cha